The Master of Scarlett and Hensle gave them
a system of linear equations to solve.
Each of them has taken several steps that have led
to the systems shown in the table below.
So, this is the system of teacher's equations.
She received Scarlett after she had done several steps.
That's got Hanks.
Which one has received a system,
equivalent to the teacher's system?
And just to remember,
equivalent to a given system is,
at least for our purpose,
a system that has the same solution,
or the same set of decisions as the one given.
If there is a precisely defined pair (x, y)
which satisfies the teacher's system,
in order for Scarlett's system to be equivalent to that system,
it must have the same solution.
Let's look at it.
Scarlett ... Let's see
whether we can connect them.
Her second equation here,
this is interesting,
its second equation 14x minus 7u is equal to 2,
here the teacher has an equation
14x minus 7u is equal to 7.
This is interesting because the ratio
between x and y is the same,
but then the permanent member,
the permanent member will be different.
And I say,
that this is already telling us that Scarlett's system
is not equivalent to that of the teacher.
You're probably wondering how can I say that?
If you write these two equations
in the type of tilt-intersection,
you will see the reason, because the ratio
between members x and y is the same.
You will have the same slope,
but you will have a different cross with the y y axis.
In fact, we can find it.
This equation is here
can be written as ... Let's see,
if we pull out 14x on both sides,
we get minus 7th
is equal
to minus 14x plus 7
and we can divide both sides to minus 7.
We get y is equal to 2x minus 1, and that is ...
I just did this algebraically.
The right is this and I can even try
to draw it.
I'll draw a quick coordinate system.
This will be a very rough drawing.
Quick coordinate axes are there
and then this right,
this right will look like this.
Its intersection with the y axis is minus 1 and it has a slope of 2.
Let me draw straight lines with slope 2,
it might seem
like this.
This is the right here
or there and ...
Let's see.
This is going to be ...
If we do the same algebraic calculations,
we will have
minus 7u is equal to minus 14x plus 2,
or y is equal, just divide everything down to minus 7,
2x minus 2/7.
This will look like this.
Its intersection point with y is minus 2/7 and it's somewhere out there.
These rights will look like this,
I will do my best
an attempt to draw it,
it will look something like ...
In fact, this is not quite accurate.
It will look like ...
I'll start here here.
Something like this.
There will be the same slope
and the same direction.
Let me draw it.
It will have the same slope,
but a different intersection with y.
That does not look right, but you get a clue.
These two do
are parallel,
therefore, no coordinate that satisfies these rights,
will not satisfy this.
They have no common points.
They are parallel.
This is the definition of parallelism.
Because this and this rights have no common points,
there is no way any of the solutions,
which satisfies this equation, also satisfies this,
because each (x, y) that satisfies this,
will not satisfy this and vice versa.
They are parallel.
They have no common points.
These two things will never cross.
So Scarlett's system is not equivalent to that of the teacher.
But what about Hanks?
We see here that Hanks is here
the same thing.
5x minus y, but then the permanent member
is different, minus 6, plus 3.
So this and this also represent parallel rows.
Each pair (x, y) that satisfies this,
will not satisfy that either.
These two rules do not intersect.
They are parallel.
Hence, the Hanks system is also not equivalent to that of the teacher.